[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thanks for joining us
oh look at this i'm drinking a hint
water
and you know they're not even a sponsor
they don't give me money but i like
their water and they give me free water
and i deliciously eat it
i eat it deliciously they should give
you some money
why because you are stocked up on this
stuff that's true
everybody comes over there can i ever
hit water i'm like sure man you can have
a hint in water
as far as i know you're the only
distributor of hint water i'm thirsty is
that a hint
water yeah they're good thank you hint
for uh
for always uh giving me free water i
hope everybody had a glorious weekend
and
uh i can't believe we're almost into
march now ryan
and uh we're all waiting for the vaccine
we're all waiting for her to just for
this
to be over we're trying to force it over
yeah
i had my moment last week boy yeah i
think if you listen to the podcast from
last week i listened to the intro
actually and i was just like
oh yeah you were uh you're a bit uh not
off my game if anything i was on my game
because
i was talking about my mental illness
um you get frustrated you get tired you
get
just uh the anxiety kind of kicks in and
and
and this has been a bit better this last
weekend i sort of
got away rob and i went to joshua tree
nice rob my guitarist for the band
sunspin we
we drove up there and we got a place and
just this little place was like the
pioneer motel
a cute little place and we just hiked
and
went through a little western town and
just disconnected and i'm telling you
just to get out of town did something
for my mental health just to get away
from the norm the
the uh redundancy of of life that we
just it's every day do the same thing
and if you just keep doing that it's
going to drive you crazy
yeah my sister just went to joshua tree
too this is her first time there
uh i think so uh but uh they she has a
dog
uh she and a boyfriend have a dog and so
they went to like an art like an rv
park so they're just like out
in the desert just sort of out and so it
looked nice it does look nice i saw my
first shining
shining first shooting star i'd never
seen a shooting star and i looked up in
the sky at night at joshua
for the very first night i go oh it's a
shooting star
rob's like you've never seen a shooting
so i'm like no i think if you see a
shooting star you have to say it in that
accent
it's a shooting star
i loved it man it was uh it was a nice
escape i need to
i need to get out more i need to do
things you know and we wear masks and
[ __ ]
so that was good uh thank you guys for
everything by the way the
sunspin album is out look cds you can
get this awesome cd
at sunspin.com along with tons of
awesome merch like
lunch boxes and stone coasters and hats
trucker hats i got my
trucker hat here that was the dilemma
this morning i was like ryan should i
wear the trucker hat or not you know he
was like i don't care
you know either way i don't care either
way i'm getting paid the same amount of
money
oh another thing if we sent merch out
for sunspin and if you get the
lunchbox if you've got a lunchbox um if
you make a video of yourself
opening the lunchbox and make it uh the
most original
and post it on all post instagrams uh
twitter and facebook
rob and i will choose uh the person we
thought was the most creative
and we'll do a zoom with you so um
when you get your lunch boxes make it
creative
and i will probably do that contest in a
week or so uh maybe a week or two but
it's it's starting now so when you get
that
lunch box the sunspin lunchbox which is
available on sunspin.com so thank you
everybody for coming out to stage it to
this last week it was a big show one of
our biggest
and uh if you've never been we do the
last saturday of every month so we did
saturday 2 p.m and 6 p.m two shows
we did ryan we played uh we played like
ah-ha
did you do acoustic style yeah acoustic
style we did uh what else do we do
um some talking heads home is where i
want to be
but we did a bunch of stuff but a bunch
of stuff from the album
and uh i urge you to go to sunspin.com
and check out our album we're also
available on itunes right now but you
have to get it off your computer to get
this
downloads and all that jazz so yeah the
cd it's fun to have a
something tangible that you can go hey
look this i did this i worked very hard
for this
that's cool i didn't know you made like
huh people still buy cds we've already
sold like 100 cds you have vinyl too
uh we're thinking about getting vinyl
more of a keepsake thing
but uh thanks again for tuning in uh
last week was a really fun episode with
katie cassidy and we had michael cudlitz
from the walking dead the week before
we've got a very special guest he's been
on the podcast a few times but he always
has so much information
and this time around i feel like he was
more open there was a
there was just more of a vulnerability
to zach if you could even say that
because he's a vulnerable
down-to-earth man and uh and i consider
him a real good friend and he just he's
a he's a listener
and i love having him on it gives me a
chance to um
breathe a little bit and see that there
are people that are going through the
same [ __ ] and him you know when he talks
about
the medications that he's on and what
works for him and it's just
so open you don't see a lot of people do
that and that's just uh
it's just i really respect that and it
helps a lot of the listeners that are
listening go hey
this guy who's shazam he's he's got
problems too and uh
that's the whole point so uh i urge you
guys also if you can
i always say it but it really helps if
you take a minute out to write a review
on apple podcasts uh subscribe on
youtube
and apple podcast spotify wherever you
listen please subscribe
and please invite many friends to listen
it's it's word of mouth that really gets
the podcast growing and growing and
it's a very specific podcast that we
talk about you know this is a
we talk about adversity and stress and
life and it's really a candid
conversation so i don't think they're a
lot
like this and that's a good and a bad
thing it's a good thing for
you know for the world i guess and
people listening but also people
you know there's so many choices out
there so i'm glad that you're
i'm your choice at least for now so uh
thank you for that and uh where can they
subscribe to the podcast ryan uh on
youtube.com inside of you with michael
rosenbaum and then there's also
follow ability i started that sentence
and i didn't know how to end it
uh inside of you pod on the twitters and
uh
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook yes
yeah i like that i hope you continue to
listen and uh join patreon my patreon
family is growing and growing and we do
a lot of great things in fact i just
bought
uh if you've been a patreon for a patron
for a year
i made shirts for those top tiers who
have been there for since the inception
of patreon which i didn't know what the
hell was when i first started
but if you want to get closer to the
podcast a little closer to me a little
you know we have our barriers but uh i
talked to a lot of folks there and
um it's a wonderful wonderful platform
so go to patreon.com
inside of you patreon.com
inside of you i think that's that's what
it is it is uh
so look without further ado i think
let's get inside a guy who's
constantly working who is uh
an inspiration to a lot of people
including myself he got me into a great
place which
cleared my head for a while and might
have to go back
but uh let's get inside of my good buddy
zach levi it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
how deep is your love how deep is
harmonized
i really need to know
cause well
how deep is your love i go how deep is
your love
how deep is your love i really need
to know cause we're living
in a world of fools
[Music]
is that marina background over your left
shoulder it kind of does look like a
mirena but uh no it's just some random
piece of art in this
house that i'm staying in what how whose
house are you in
uh i'm in a rental house at oklahoma in
oklahoma city because
you're filming what are you filming well
i was filming a movie called the
unbreakable boy
and we finished that and then i went
home for the holidays for a couple of
weeks and
uh then i'm coming back and basically
with like 50
of the same crew we're about to shoot
this movie american underdog which is
the kurt warner
um football quarterback right you're
kurt warner
yeah yeah have you been practicing oh
yeah
can you throw a football can you throw a
football i could throw a football pretty
well i mean i don't know that i throw it
as good as kurt warner but you know i
mean
geez louise you know when you throw that
good you play in the nfl
that's true but uh yeah no i've been
i've been doing a lot of like um
uh strength and conditioning uh training
uh
all through like once i got to oklahoma
i started uh training and all through
shooting the last film i was doing that
and
and also um some qb training even before
i came to oklahoma i had a qb coach
who's now here in oklahoma with me and
we're gonna be running drills and
you know just getting just getting
formed down and making sure
not even just how to throw a football
well
uh or you know um what it means to be a
quarterback but specifically
to emulate curt as best i can and so you
know
he my quarterback coach is kind of
breaking down the various things that
you know kurt would do is the way he
steps back in the pocket the way he kind
of
bounces the way whatever it is how you
move with the ball how your head's
moving
do you move your head at all and
unfortunately i was even able to
um in this little holiday break i was
able to i road tripped uh
me and my girlfriend road trip from la
to phoenix and i was able to go hang out
with her warner and his family
uh for a couple of days and just absorb
them and their dynamic and their you
hung out with kurt warner for a few days
like at his house
yeah yeah isn't that bizarre is that
like john beiner remember john beiner
it was super bizarre i've never really
done
i i you know like the unbreakable boy
that i did prior to this
is a is kind of a biopic
in that it's about a real family and i
was representing and i was
playing the husband and father in this
real family
but um he and i very looked very
different
in real life and you know the the movie
has a lot of it takes a lot of
not a lot of but i mean it takes enough
of our artistic liberty to kind of you
know
create it and weave it all together in
the way that those things typically do
and no one's gonna be i don't i you know
the public scrutiny isn't looking at me
and this other gentleman scott loretta
his name is right
nobody's being like wait a minute but
everybody knows kurt warner so
there's a whole another level of
scrutiny that you're under when you're
when you're representing being someone
that is so well known and famous i think
well look as as a as someone who you
know i know sports i i play football i
could actually throw the ball i'm not
you know i'm not bullshitting i could
throw you know
i have videos of me throwing a ball i
could throw a freaking football i mean i
believe i can i'm telling you obviously
nobody's
you know kurt warner level i mean you
know tom brady but like kurt warner
what is interesting about if i don't
know anything about football why would i
go see a curt warner what what is the
catch
what is the same question yeah i mean
what's it what's it interesting what's
the story like in an in a nutshell don't
break it down but just
in a nutshell the movie's not really
about the football the football
is the packaging in that like it's
it's an incredible rags to riches
cinderella story and the nfl is one of
the most insane places that ever
try and even make that thing happen but
it's 25
football 75 percent the real life
journey of kurt and brenda and their and
their kids
their kids and it's beautiful
it's got so much heart and so much faith
and um
it just is it's a very uh it's a very
uh uplifting yeah uplifting humbling
uh uh encouraging story
we need that i think we need more of
that oh my god i need more of it i need
more of it
you know so i love it buddy we were
talking like a couple of months ago and
i know
we were both like struggling a little
bit and we we get into these struggles
i mean we as in everyone listening we
all get into these modes of like
you know where we see the light at the
end of the tunnel and all of a sudden it
goes dark again and you're like what
just happened man i thought things are
going well my mind's not
like for instance me uh you know i i
kind of
tried some meds out just to just to kind
of balance me nothing major but
it it's kind of messed with me a little
bit you know it's like uh
i told ryan the day of my engineer i'm
like i'm just dizzy
um a little lightheaded uh you know and
my my therapist seems to think it's like
you know uh
i the antibiotics that i'm antibiotics
that i'm taking and he gives he thinks
it's throwing it off and
just to give it a few days but talk
about not sleeping i have a little
insomnia now i'm like it's just like
and to try and get to a normal and a lot
of people will say
well try nothing well i've tried nothing
and now i'm trying a little something
to see if this little something will
help me feel normal because the normal
that i
feel i don't necessarily love and i'd
like to feel
some semblance of normal normalcy so
you know i know we were both struggling
a little bit and i get into these areas
and that's
hence why i wanted to try something and
go hey you know what i want to try
something a little something and see if
it gives me a little bit of help and uh
and i know you've done that too and i
know you've been working on yourself but
what have you been doing
because i know work is your therapy and
it kind of detaches you
or maybe connects you so what do you
what do you do
well so yeah man so many things to
unpack
i know i didn't know where to start so i
was like no no it's perfect what do you
want to get into
the way our conversations go it's all
going to tangent and
and get eventually we'll cover
everything so yeah
um true so yeah so well one of the
things that
um well for people who are at home uh or
in their car or wherever you're
listening or watching
listening to or watching this podcast um
this is now the third uh of
of the michael and zach sessions uh
number three was supposed to be
in texas uh where
i was going to interview michael and
then we were also going to do a live
um uh inside of you on a stage there but
the pandemic happened
and then pandemic happened and all that
stuff two sold out shows in austin
gone and it was it was it was it's okay
we'll come back to it
we'll do it all in god's timing man
we're okay yeah um
but also you know um an update and and
um kind of an impetus or catalyst as to
why
we're you know um jumping in because i
really wanted
i like doing this in person i i mean
design is amazing and what it's been
able to
provide us and this specific time is
just incredible
um but yeah you know i always like the
the
to to be in real life uh face to face
would it help if i touch the screen
yeah i just reach out read it shout out
and
touch oh you got something on your
forehead somebody's hand i'm sorry about
that
when your grandma has to do that or your
mom they lick a finger to wipe something
off of your face oh yeah and it smells
her finger smell
one of the uh the catalysts or you know
to why we're
having this number three right now is
because
prior to the pandemic uh and i've shared
all this
stuff with you michael but you know um i
was
i was in the process of writing a book i
mean i was in a
much better place than where i was three
years ago as i've shared with uh with
you and the listeners
um i went through a whole breakdown
three and a half
years three and a half ish or so years
ago when i first moved out to austin and
just
uh didn't realize how much i didn't love
myself or or feel any self-worth at all
and i did so much work and went to
incredible therapy as a place of privy
swiss as we've talked about
and with those amazing people yeah and
um
and shazam comes out of that and
marvelous mrs mazel and all of these
things
just felt like okay i've done the work
and i've healed of this thing and now
look at the
fruit of that labor and i'm good i'm
good now and i didn't realize just how
ungood
i was i didn't realize just how little
healing i had done
uh and amazing by the way it's it's an
incredible i think example and testament
to god's love we
even a little bit of work that we do can
bring about such incredible growth and
such incredible things
but i still had so much more to do and i
didn't realize it until the pandemic hit
when i fell apart i come i crumbled and
when it when it first started i was
actually okay and i felt optimistic and
then once the country started ripping
apart at the seams
and there was just all of this vitriol
and all like we're
so and as an empath i like not only did
i feel all that and feel like what is
like i lost hope like what is the point
of even working toward all these things
we're working toward if everybody's
going to hate each other at the on the
other side of this and
um and also me just you know all the
negative
loop that we find ourselves you know uh
um these lies that stay in our head and
we can't get out of our head like you're
worthless or you're you're
dumb or you're not or you're ugly or
whatever all of the things
and um and this was i was in the process
of writing a book
because harper collins had hit me up and
they were like listen we really want
to we want you to write a book about
your mental health journey specifically
this one that i've talked about many
times before
you know kind of um the the
going away to this healing
therapy retreat and then becoming a
superhero on the other end of that like
you know this um a really powerful
uh part of what my you know very long
mental health journey has been
and i was in the thick of that and i was
literally
trying to write this book to help people
to talk about loving yourself
like i've done many times on my social
media and
i couldn't i literally couldn't do it
i could not without feeling like i was a
complete
fraud and hypocrite i couldn't write a
book about loving yourself when i knew
still deep down i didn't love myself
and i was so messed up this pandemic
because i
i i just went right back to feeling like
a complete failure do you remember
plans on all these things do you
remember the messages that you and i
kind of left back and forth
i just remember this voice and
i'll tear up the [ __ ] thinking about
it i was like hey buddy it's rosie just
uh
calling you seeing how you're doing and
you're like hey bud
uh you know and just the feeling like
you could tell that you were like i'm
really trying here
and i'm sitting in my truck right now
and
and i have that message and it just was
like it broke my heart and i was like
it broke my heart but at the same time i
you know it was almost in a weird way
nice to hear somebody that can maybe
relate to how you're feeling so i didn't
want you to feel like that but but i
felt like you know i immediately
facetimed you and i go hey
let's talk and we talked for a long time
and we were you know we
weren't expecting to but it just was
like i know you have you've
really stayed away from a lot of
medication for a long time and this and
that and we were kind of talking about
hey
look we got to try something and i
remember you know you you're right you
went to
this place and then i went to that place
because i
respect you so much and love you so much
that i was like you know i'm going to do
this for me
i remember you said what's your biggest
investment what's your big the most
important thing to you i go i don't know
the most expensive things probably my
house i guess you go
nope i don't know my van isn't worth
much
you're like no buddy you you're the most
important with your
that [ __ ] is nothing without you if
you're not healthy who gives a [ __ ]
health is wealth
and that struck a chord man and i was
off to connecticut and
just trying to better myself and so then
afterwards we i feel better and we're
like oh you were right this really
helped and then like you were in good
place and all of a sudden we find
ourselves
back into this lull and then it's like
well what just happened i thought we
fixed ourselves that
but then we realized it's a never-ending
battle it's a never-ending
like you have to work on yourself and so
and then here we are
well i think yeah i think it's it's
never ending but i but i i
i used to be much more downtrodden by
that
like i hate the idea of you know forever
pain
forever inconvenience forever whatever
but
i think that similar to
you know if if you you know i've used
the dental analogy before with mental
health but
um if you never learned to brush and
floss your teeth
or you learned but you never did it your
whole life you're going to end up with
all manner of problems in your teeth
and then at that point you're going to
have to do some major major major work
to get it all
fixed good analogy and then beyond that
you're going to have to then continue to
do the things
that you were supposed to do in the
beginning and had you done those daily
those
little practices brush your teeth flush
your teeth
if you brush your teeth floss your teeth
every day which is you know
five minutes 10 minutes if you're slow
then you don't have to have root canals
if mentally and emotionally which by the
way this is everybody because
no one has been taught really good
mental and emotional flossing and
brushing techniques
unless you grow up with therapists and
even that's a weird
thing because therapists being parents
like i have friends whose parents are
therapists and
they're screwed up too so yeah you know
there's all those things but
so so yes it is a never ending our
mental and emotional
uh well-being journeys are never ending
but they don't have to be never-ending
traumas
it's just an it's a never-ending
maintenance
and and i think that um where i found
myself and
where you found yourself and where i
think a lot of i
don't think i know a lot of people find
themselves um
is how do you
how do you even where do you start
well yeah how do you what's what's what
kickstarts you
into into wanting to care for yourself
if your serotonin and dopamine levels
are so low
that a depression clinical depression
even that's what i've definitely
suffered from
throughout my life i didn't realize that
i did i again we always think that
everyone just kind of feels the way that
we feel it's
normal we don't realize that some people
don't get into the lows
that some of us can get into and when i
first went uh to connecticut well when i
went to connecticut
um to prevent the
um am i allowed to say their name on
here by the way
yeah okay you went to a place that
helped you no i know i just didn't i
went to mcdonald's
not a burger you know what are they
gonna assume um
so so i was taking um uh lexapro
uh which is an ssri an antidepressant
and
i and maybe it was just because i didn't
take it long enough or i didn't take
uh the right dosage of it but it never
really felt like it helped me at all so
right because everybody's brain
chemistry is different so some people it
helps
amazingly some people it doesn't yeah i
think i had tried that in the past and
didn't yeah and there are so many
different
ssris antidepressants because of that
because your particular brain chemistry
might respond better to prozac like
which is what i'm about to get into
which is something i've been taking
uh for the last few months now which has
been a game changer for me i'll get into
that
um but with alexa pro i didn't really
feel like anything was working and i got
some really good
wisdom and love and and healing at prive
and um and i and i really was that you
know we all kind of have that thing and
it's like well i don't want to have to
take a pill for the rest of my life i
don't want to have to do that well
guess what sometimes you do and that's
okay
sometimes we are all born
i mean there are people that are born
missing
an arm right what if they said well i
don't want to have to use a
um prosthetic for the rest of my life
well they're just cutting off their nose
despite their face right
you have a thing to help you to reach
that thing to grab that thing
but you're not going to use it because
you don't want to have to be dependent
on it by the way
i've never been born without an arm and
i don't know what that journey is like
but it it would seem to me that
in that same way we we need to be
approaching again physical well-being
should be equatable to mental and
emotional well-being it should be we
just
we we have so many stigmas around it we
don't want to feel like we're the person
that has to take a drug
a pill every day even right you feel
shame like why can't i be normal oh my
god why can't i
am i not strong enough am i am i too
weak and that was a stigma that's been
around since the beginning of all this
[ __ ]
and it's [ __ ] and anybody everybody
listening is [ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] whatever works for you
obviously if cocaine works for you
you're
don't do that that's a bad thing but if
you have something that's controlled
that's
works for your brain chemistry and you
go through it with your therapist that
you feel comfortable and it makes you
feel
like normal like you can get things done
you're not going into these deep
you know uh dark areas and so that
that's
i i agree with you wholeheartedly and
the analogy with the uh not flossing
your teeth just makes perfect sense i
mean it really does because one day you
wake up and you're like
oh my god my whole mouth they need to
rip out my all my teeth
well that's the exact same thing if you
wait to your uh our age
oh you're 40 40. you're 40. i'm 48. [ __ ]
me
in the butt or anywhere you look great
well i don't know thank you it's been
i'll tell you what my daddy always told
me it's better to feel good than to look
it's better to look good than to feel
good let me tell you
you look you don't remember that guy you
look absolutely
marvelous fernando and sarah you my
daddy always told me fernando don't be a
schnook it's not how you feel it's how
you look
okay that's billy chris billy crystal
yes
baby inside of you is brought to you by
better help
stop right now if you're freaking out if
you're stressed about the uh
the way the world is now or just life in
general
anxiety depression all this stuff if you
deal with stuff like i do and
everybody deals with everybody deals
with
you deserve help you deserve to get
better help um
better help online counseling um they
are a sponsor for a long time
and uh they're serious about helping
people and so am i and that's why i
think it's a good match
2020 was pretty interesting so uh let's
do a mental health check-in why don't we
how are you really ask yourself and what
do you need right now
therapy can help and you know people ask
what is therapy exactly
and they sum it up pretty good it's
really whatever you want it to be
uh that's therapy it you know you get
tools
to help with motivation depression
anxiety
battling your temper stress dealing with
insecurity in relationships or at work
whatever you need it's not just i think
people associate it with
it you know this big
sort of what's the word ryan it's just
this this stigma of you know
oh people that need therapy or no that's
absolutely not true i always say people
who don't go to therapy
are you know what i'm saying it's time
to stop being ashamed of normal human
struggles and start feeling
better because you deserve to be happy
better help is a customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to and it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and trust me i live in hollywood
it's expensive so better help is way
cheaper and you could start
communicating with your therapist within
48 hours
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about it
may or may not be for you
but it is certainly worth looking into
because you
are the greatest asset this podcast is
sponsored by better help and inside of
you listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside better help inside of you is
brought to you by
athletic greens guys i don't know
what what to do here with you guys
because you know you wake up in the
morning and
you do what i do you probably eat a bowl
of cereal or you eat
bacon and eggs and you don't get any
important crap going in your body
you don't get the good stuff in your
body we we neglect our bodies
and it's so easy to please them
especially with a product like athletic
greens
i mean this is something a powder that
you put into a glass of water
a 10-ounce glass of water you mix it up
in seconds
it's got 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin
multimineral probiotic green superfood
blend
and more and they all work together to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
you increase your
energy better focus
aids with digestion and supports a
healthy immune system all without having
to take
multiple products this is again
something i talk about
if you're getting whether you're young
or not but i'm getting older i i don't i
need to
start doing healthy things ryan do you
find yourself
just doing the same crap every day oh
especially now for sure and what are you
eating in the morning
i mean i do eggs and some toast and you
think oh
eggs are kind of healthy yeah toast is
but are you do you honestly gun to your
head
think you're getting enough vitamins and
nutrients and minerals in your body
every day
no way hell no it's so easy i gave you
some packets of the athletic
greens it's it's tasty it's not like you
think oh my gosh i'm gonna have to hold
my nose you know there's some of those
drinks where you plug your nose and
you're like oh
shoot here we go no man this tastes good
it tastes good give it a shot
get your life together start your day
with athletic greens
it works for me it gives me energy i
know when i don't take it because i
could fall asleep right now
talking to you right now athletic greens
is doubling down on supporting
your immune system during the winter
months they are offering our audience
a free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase
if you visit the link today you'll
basically never have to buy vitamin d
again
it's that easy start today guys give
this a shot simply visit
athleticgreens.com y
o u join health experts
athletes and health conscious go-getters
around the world who make a daily
commitment to their health every day
again athleticgreens.com
you and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
so go back to you because i know you're
saying prozac and by the way i want to
commend you for being
very not only straightforward but like
also
it's it's very brave for people
especially in our industry
to go oh i'm on this or i'm like people
think oh but that shows a weakness like
i've had surgeries i deal with pain
oh he's a liability no i'm just being
honest with the world and i mean
i do what i can and uh i just think it
helps and again
whatever whenever you talk about this as
i'm sure you're saying we've talked
about
it's not like prozac will work for
everybody prozac might work for you
so anyway go ahead in fact you know i
actually
well i share it because i think it's
important as you know
i just think i think vulnerability is
important and transparency
superpower i think it helps it feels
awkward and scary to
be that real uh but it has only ever
brought positive things into mind and
other people's lives me too
so i don't want to hide and not talk
about the struggles that i have
particularly since we have a platform
that we do and i think that the more we
can normalize and we have platforms to
really spread that normalization out
there
so that's super helpful the only thing
that i've ever questioned
uh talking about the brand or type of
uh pharmaceutical is something that
actually i learned
was it when chris cause they'll give you
bank you as a spokesperson like oh he
says this
no it's not it's not even that it's um
it was something i heard kristen bell
saying it was either on your podcast or
was on um
yeah on armchair well she said she
wouldn't name the product because she
doesn't want other people it was you
know it was a mine where she said
she doesn't want other people to think
exactly right that doesn't work for them
just because it worked for her so she
didn't say that
so that's exactly what i was alluding to
and i think that's and that's the only
hesitancy i even
have in talking with uh talking about
what i'm taking but i'm gonna talk about
it
uh because we're also giving people the
um the uh
clarity in our conversation right now
that this
just because it works for me doesn't
mean it works for you and by the way i'm
not even sure it works for me
uh perfectly right now you know there's
things that work
uh and there's things that that don't
work when i um well
first tracking back a little bit so
again i was even though i was in like
really really really uh you know sad
shape and feeling super defeated and
uh lost and incapable uh
and you know all of the not good things
um i tried i still was like i don't want
to
i don't want to have to take a pill if i
don't have to i'm going to do all of the
other things
and and things that i've done before but
i was really like
leaning into it i was praying
uh exercise meditating daily uh
20 20 minutes a day sometimes 40 minutes
a day
20 in the in the morning and 20 at night
um
[Music]
there's a great app by the way my friend
turned me on to if anybody's looking to
get into meditation
one giant mind write that down right
like
they walk you through um i thought
you're going to say j-date
isn't that for jews like myself i'm a
jew you're you're giant
so so it's meditating um was working out
every day was eating the cleanest of
clean wasn't drinking any booze
and i still and it still was not
pulling me out of the depths and
it was terrifying and i was like well i
i i can't if this is if i'm doing all
these things and it doesn't really feel
like i'm having consistent
market difference in the uptick of my
life
and i guess that's the sign that i do
need to try
something um and you know as it turned
out
had people like yourself or others who
were saying
you know zack maybe it's time that you
really give
an anti-depressant a shot and one of the
things that really put me over the edge
not to uh plug somebody else's podcast
but i think it's definitely worth
mentioning and something you'd really
enjoy listening
to it's a podcast called the hilarious
world of depression
and it's uh i can't remember the name of
the host but he's great
um and he interviews just basically a
bunch of comedy the first couple of
seasons are just
mainly comedians um and comic writers
but then he brings in other people from
entertainment and stuff and
i want to get on there we should both
get on there oh we definitely should
at some point i would love to to do it
but anyway the point is is that
he introduced all these people and all
of them
you know it's it's without fail it's
like yeah i didn't want to i didn't want
to take the pill i didn't want to
we all have this this kit we want to
kick back on this thing
and they all say change my life change
my life changed my life changed my life
changed my life
i couldn't get out of bed and then i was
all of a sudden like i'm okay again
and i i think it's i think part of it is
none of us want to admit
how uh
do we need help well no no yes but but
also i think that
i think that people don't want to admit
the idea
that we are just how helpless we are
to our body's biochemistry i think we
all think
that we are in control of that and
and it's actually a very liberating
concept to
acknowledge and to say oh no no i don't
like all of my thoughts are not my
thoughts my thoughts
are a whole bunch of things sometimes
that's me thinking a lot of times that
is this negative interject this this
negative feedback loop
and so much of that stuff directly comes
from your level of dopamine or serotonin
or
whatever the effing effort in or
epinephrine epinephrine epinephrine i
guess yeah my thoughts are
i don't want a lot of these thoughts
yeah
totally 100 but because your body and
your mind are in
a depressed state because of dopamine
serotonin
uh lacking in your system you are
infinitely more prone to stay subject to
those thoughts
as soon as you can take some
antidepressants
or whatever it is that you need to take
for you and your particular mental and
emotional well
well-being uh journey um you can find a
key
and and here's the other thing it
shouldn't shock anybody
that we all have mental and emotional
issues look at the world
look at the world that that that was
before us and all of the
woes and all the crazy and look at where
we're at now look at these
little devils that are in our pockets
that you know like if you watch the
social dilemma the
uh documentary on netflix which is like
so scary to think about like you you're
not even in charge of your own social
media
you're being constantly marketed to and
we all know it we talk
our phone is in dude i swear to god
you're absolutely right i
i was sitting with my friend joe outside
and we're sitting there talking i don't
remember exactly what was said and i'm
just going to say for random i was like
it's like yeah
it's like you know when i got this taco
at taco bell last week
i'm not kidding 10 seconds later he just
looked at his phone goes
dude you're not going to believe this
yeah it's instagram
for taco bell i'm not on my phone so
they are
pretty much listening to you you cannot
trust any oh it's a it's a
it's terrifying so and kids are growing
up with us more and more and more and
more we're constantly just distracted
distracted from working on ourselves the
longer we get distracted
the longer it takes for us to actually
come to emotional and mental wellness
and maturity
and these things are the greatest they
are the i say i've said this for years
it's the it is the single
greatest swiss army knife in the history
of mankind and also the deepest
narcissist pool we we you can get lost
in it
black mirror that's good they're good
they love me i love them
i need that i need this in that darkness
yeah that's true that's true
so none of us should feel ashamed that
we struggle with stress and anxiety and
depression and
bipolar whatever all of the things our
brains are being fractured
every single day by our politicians by
our food by our pharma by our
social media by all of it by so much of
our content
yes but by the way zach it's not just
that
the most important thing is we have all
those external things going on because
you could also have the choice to use
those things and the choice to
acknowledge things and be as pre but
what i'm going to say
is that there are some choices look i
think i don't think you can control much
but you
you can control your determination to
fight for a better life to feel better i
mean you could always
have control of trying but what i was
going to say
is that if someone has uh schizophrenia
someone has manic depressive someone has
bipolar
this is science these are doctors who
have diagnosed these people
and if they get diagnosed by enough
doctors then it is real with science so
their mind works in a different way
their brain chemistry just
the channels that are going around
they're not like mine or yours and my
brain is not like you
so ultimately it's asinine to think that
everybody has a normal brain and we all
can improve our brain by just exercise
like
zach said that he tried that his food
his meditation all these things
so if you've done everything and your
therapist goes i
really think that this slow dose of
something might
it's worth a shot i mean that's why i'm
diving into it i don't want to be all
meted up i don't want to
i go look this is going to [ __ ] with my
creativity this is going to [ __ ] with
blah blah
i mean there are side effects like i
said well you're not going to want to
have sex as much i'm like well it's a
pandemic i don't really understand
anyway but uh you know so ultimately
it's like uh
there's so many variables but look into
your world now where you decided okay
i'm good because i remember you did not
want to like i don't know i don't want
to try prozac i don't want to do this i
i don't know i don't know
and i remember having that conversation
with you going dude if nothing's working
and you've tried everything why don't
you try something
man just if you don't like it get off it
you know just be
monitor it talk to your friends i think
part of the difficulty in this is that
you're asking
almost without fail you're always
asking a depressed person
what they should do a depressed person
doesn't know what to do they're scared
of doing almost anything because you
don't want to make it worse
right so it's it's it's a really weird
oxymoron right it's
it's this paradox like of course the
depressed person is not thinking clearly
or or as rationally or as logically as
they
ought to be as as somebody who's been on
prozac now for a couple of months
and has my serotonin levels stabilized
that makes it complete it's so much more
rational also because i've now done it
and i've seen the benefits of it and so
obviously that all plays into it too but
but you know you and and others who i
talked to
who um
[Music]
had also gone through you know uh uh
seasons of their life where they were on
it for a while and they said listen
it it it changed it it was a life it was
a lifesaver it was a life changer it was
it it helped me
you know my therapist um use a great
analogy
when you know when i talk to him about
like i don't want to be on this stuff
for the rest of my life he goes well
maybe you will and maybe you won't it
doesn't
i i don't know but they're you know like
i said they're
uh there are plenty of people like
diabetes diabetics have to take a shot
well now they actually they have these
cool little machines and things like
kind of automatic but
you know i mean i remember having
diabetic buddies when i was growing up
it's like
every single time they ate they had to
prick their finger and check their uh
that should be a sitcom by the way
diabetic buddies
it's like three overweight guys or
underweight i have friends who are
really skinny with diabetes but you know
they get it and they live
they live together and they have to
check yeah yeah stupid idea you know so
that that could be the rest of your life
perhaps but but you know also if you're
if you're in a room and you're in the
dark
and the only way to turn the light on is
to
drag a stool over
to underneath the light so you have
something to stand on so you can reach
the light
then look at the antidepressants or
whatever
drugs that you might need to take is
that stool yeah and just get up there
and get that light on i love it
once you've got the light on then assess
then look at what's going on you know
then
you can leave the light on believe the
ladder
hey let me ask you what was it like the
first month
or two when you did do prozac and were
you like
talking about getting off it and saying
this isn't working this isn't working
were there many times you almost got off
it oh man
there was yeah so so um um
yeah i mean well libido is definitely
something that is
uh side effect that is very clear um
uh in in all of the you know like
this may cause this than the other yeah
uh so there's yeah
there's there there's there's some of
that but i don't lose a bone
i don't lose the boner i i i just don't
feel like using the boner
yeah it's like hey go down dude i don't
know what you're doing that doesn't
yeah yeah i just don't feel like doing
it like that's a that's a very good way
to
it's a very good way to uh summarize it
bone be gone
um but um no but but that that is
whatever you can you can deal with that
[ __ ] the thing that made me
um almost
get off of it uh and i'm glad i didn't
and i'm glad my therapist encouraged me
to push through um
and this is a good disclaimer for
anybody who is thinking about getting on
antidepressants
uh just keep this in mind
uh in my case so i started on
um you know a small
small milligram dose five milligrams or
something of prozac
uh for the first couple of because you
you gotta you gotta like you know you
wanna ease into these things they're
it's it's very delicate to all this
biochemistry and you wanna make sure
that you're putting the right stuff in
and it's not having adverse effects
so five milligrams golden but doesn't
didn't really feel like it was lifting
me up that much um 10
still not much so then i was able to go
to 20
uh and when i did for like the first
couple days i was okay and then for
about a week
i had gnarly anxiety now i was already
suffering from anxiety i've always i
suffer from anxiety
without uh that so i was that was one of
the things i'm trying to get away from
right and it ended up amplifying my
anxiety
uh in a way that was like i
i can't do this especially while you're
working you're doing the underdog you're
doing all these other things you're
preparing for these movies
you can't have horrible anxiety no no no
so what happens you fight through that
anxiety or you did that
i just went through it and i talked to
those closest around me just to be like
hey just know if i'm like you know
uh needing to go take a walk or
or i'm just you know breathing or it
looks like i'm just like
you know resting or whatever like i'm
just trying to i'm just trying to
breathe
breathe through this stuff and know that
and know that
this is not real it is
biochemistry making something
feel real and that's what i'm talking
about like we are not
we are not humble enough when it comes
to how strong and powerful our minds are
like we think these depressive thoughts
because we're down in this depressive
state
and then we believe these depressive
thoughts
as truth they're not how people you know
how often we sit around we're in a
bummed out mood
and think about like all the [ __ ] that
we did wrong in our life and we beat
ourselves up about ruminating
ruminating or we think about oh that
stupid thing i did with that person and
they must think i'm an idiot
and all of all of those projections when
that person
might not have even clocked what you did
or cares
and even if they did they haven't
thought about you in 20 years yeah
whatever
but to you it is real and clear as the
day
yeah but it's not because our
biochemistry literally makes us
feel in such a way that it galvanizes
that it like solidifies it as some kind
of fact and it's a [ __ ] lie it's not
true
so what yeah i knew that was going on my
therapist is like you got to remind
yourself this is just a physical
reaction there is nothing to be
anxious about because if you're feeling
anxiety then you'll apply that anxiety
onto things in your life and you'll feel
that anxiety about those things
as opposed to just feeling it you know
it's very i think it's a very buddhist
kind of thing to
allow yourself to just feel whatever it
is you're feeling
the meta this is very in meditation it's
the same thing it's
feel what you're feeling become bed
fellows with your pain with your fear
with your anxiety with your depression
like i'll
you know embrace them but what was the
first thing you felt
in a good way like in terms of like oh
it's working or did it take you
time to sort of as my therapist would
say hey tell anxiety he could sit in the
back seat but he's not driving and shut
the [ __ ]
up i know it's there this is what's
happening but that's not that's just
that's not real
he could sit in the back seat he's there
we know he's there but keep driving
and or was there a moment where like you
woke up or
day two and you're like my anxiety is
kind of gone i don't feel low
i'm not i mean honestly like once all
the anxiety kind of
leveled up even while the anxiety was
going on i could still feel the
depression
lessening so that was i could feel
not happier necessarily but i could
i didn't feel as unhappy or yeah or like
depressed it was just the anxiety that
was still so once
so once that then leveled off
and things kind of stabilized um i don't
feel the anxiety
thank god uh and
my therapist was right and just you know
write that out and don't take you know
because i was like do i take
something to counteract that and he goes
don't take any more things just
write it out it sucks but you're gonna
be okay
and um and now um
you know it's it's strange it's like you
know because you i guess you just assume
or because people
for so many years say that they're happy
pills or whatever antidepressants
but they're not really happy pills that
it's not like you know
um uh
flying and just like oh my god like some
drug truck you're just you're actually
as
as somebody who struggles with the
depression as i do
you i think this is just what people
feel like ignoring right it's normalcy i
the happy pills really i'd like here
comes my normal pill
i can feel kind of like maybe you
yeah yeah no that's true that's true
that's that's kind of
where it's at now and it's and that
allows
me to now not be run by this
monkey brain it's down in the depressive
state that's
thinking lies are real and instead
you know like getting all of that like
um at a therapist once talked about like
you know
perspective and why we get so strung out
it's like putting your hand in front of
your face
if you put your hand right in front of
your face you actually can't see the
form
of your hand you you know it's your hand
but you know it's all kind of
double visioned and you know there's no
real clear lines and until you can pull
your hand
away far enough from your face then you
can go oh that's the hand i can see all
the fingers i can see all of the
lines in it i can but you have no
perspective here
there's nothing here and this is where
we're at in our messed up
biochemistry we have no it's everything
like how many people you think just did
that
with with me how many people watching
just put their hand in their face
and went along with them going oh my god
i did i was lost in zack's words
and his hand
inside of you is brought to you by true
underdog podcast
raised in a trailer park with no clear
path to success
kicked out of high school multiple times
faced with becoming a father in his
teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or he can't
too many times he unleashed the power
within to start three successful
companies
with his most recent venture power home
solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion dollar
enterprise join us as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year winner
shares motivational tips and inspiring
stories and business building lessons
from the ground
up he shares his life experiences and
that of his high profile guests
to help others better themselves as
waller will tell you there's no elevator
to success
that climb only happens one step at a
time let every true underdog podcast be
that step that elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting or making excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
check out true
underdog podcast at trueunderdog.com
or anywhere you get your podcasts inside
of you is brought to you by geico
do you own or rent a home ryan i have a
home i know you rent a home
i do rent a home and it's a pain in the
ass pain in the ass that's the biggest
thing we always talk about this but
it's funny because uh you know i'm 48
years old man and you're
32 almost 30. all right go to hell uh
you're young
uh but you're more mature than i am but
no matter what i i think the older you
get
you don't want to do as much you don't
want to pay as many bills
you don't want to go out there's just a
lot of things that you want to save
time with groceries
auto insurance homeowners insurance
all these things that just sound so
adult you want somebody that's respected
that everybody knows but at the same
time you want to be able to do
one payment and those are called
bundling policies it's so easy honestly
with geico
and uh you know to have one payment and
that's all you have to deal with as
opposed to three different companies
to me that's uh that's what's important
in my life i'll tell you that right now
geico makes it easy
to bundle your homeowners or renters
insurance along with your
auto policy go to geico.com all you do
is get a quote it's so simple
and see how much you could save it's
geico easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
so that's been um uh you know a huge
benefit and and continuing to do the
other things as well
um uh and
staying healthy and staying strong and
uh
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually um
you know 20 20 was
uh brutal for everybody well yeah
unless you're jeff pesos it wasn't very
brutal for him
um but uh yeah by and large we all got
smacked around really really really hard
and some of us even lost our lives and
um and we're not out of the woods yet
there's still going to be more covid
flying around
we've got the vaccines which is great
and more and more of those will be
handed out and
you know depending on how well or
efficiently we do that maybe by
summertime maybe
we have things opening to a level
that like feel real and
by q3 it's really real and by q4 by
holidays of next year
we've got hurt immunity or we're close
to it or whatever but we
we still have a lot of this to go
through and a lot of
you know political [ __ ] that we're
all gonna be wading through together
and trying to stay a hopeful
like if you want to be a productive
person you have to have some kind of
hope
you have to have some kind of faith in
something resolve
faith something where you know that it's
worth it you know
and when i'm at my highs i i
everything's worth it but when i'm in my
lows i'm like what's the point of life
yeah isn't that something what are we
doing you know and that's where i
i know that i i can swing and whether
i'm bipolar or not i i don't know i've
never been diagnosed with that but
but bipolar is a massive big catch-all
category and
there's all manner of like there's uh
there's one and two and three and three
is just like a bunch of stuff that we're
not really sure what it is but maybe it
is bipolar but we don't know and
you know when i'm happiest zach i think
when it's one in the morning and i'm on
ebay looking at old lunch boxes
vintage lunch boxes i just got this
empire strikes back one
there's something to be said about just
kind of it's not healthy
it's not healthy but you know my my
excuses
i'm not going to you know be some
douchebag i'm not going to go buy a
300 000 you know benzer or whatever
i'm just buying a 30 or 80 freaking
empire lunch box
that's it i'm not spending i'm not
spending like crazy here i might spend a
few hundred bucks here and there i'm not
i'm not going nuts but i want some
lunchboxes
there's something bad about that though
there's something dark there's something
there that i'm
what is it you're looking at me like
well
[Laughter]
you've been there because you think that
this is going to make you happier like
these certain things are going to make
you happy but it's a family ultimately
that's
it's that's retail therapy i know uh
and um and external validation on some
level
uh why i'm the only one that cares about
it i think that it's healthy and good to
treat yourself
occasionally absolutely i think that
that's part of self-love
is to say like i'm worth this thing
whatever this thing is
only we can gauge when we are
buying something because we're worth it
buying something because we want to be
worth it
and that's where i think you know a lot
of us struggle
and stumble we're not we don't give
it enough thought before
purchasing and then because once you
purchase you get the dopamine rush and
you get the fun and you get the thing
and
ah you get it but that goes away quick
really by the way that was one of the
things wow one of the things that i've
uh definitely returned um
uh kind of i think recognized for the
first time
in my career in my life um
not working well you and i have talked
about this before but when i when i
i didn't realize how much you know i
derived my
worth from work before this pandemic i
knew that i did
on some level um but
i don't know i always kind of felt like
in the past if i wasn't working it was
my fault
so i could beat myself up and there was
and that's why i was
upset with myself this was the first
time i wasn't working and it wasn't
because i hadn't booked a job or
whatever it's because this virus is
floating around the world
everything gets shut down so i should be
very kind to myself and be like okay
well okay
you know hunker down this out and we'll
get back to work on stuff once we get
back but i didn't instead
i was still feeling worthless
and i and i was like why why can't i
just
be with me i'm not
being zach on a set if i'm not being
zack with my cast and crew and
taking care of people and loving people
and entertaining people there and making
a thing
that's gonna go entertain people outside
of here for years to come why can't i
feel like i'm worth anything if i'm not
doing some version
of that or you know working and and
producing and creating why can't i
because i still didn't love myself
enough i still yeah that's
working on valuing myself enough to be
okay
if i don't do another tv show or another
movie or another play or another song or
whatever if i had to switch careers
right now and go do something else am i
going to be
happy with myself am i going to love
myself i'm trying
i'm trying i'm listening to this and i'm
going you know
my therapist is always sandy you know
sandy yeah but sandy's always like
you you're you're worth it you're and
i'm like yeah i know i know i know i
know yeah i know i'm totally worth it
yeah i know i know i'm talented i know
but but i'm not it's not it's not
settling in it's not yeah
and it's just such a weird dynamic where
it's like i don't hate myself
i don't look in the mirror and go you're
a terrible
[ __ ] awful person but i do think i
definitely can't say i love myself i
cannot
say that honest to god gun to my head
somebody said do you love yourself i
cannot say yes
that's for sure but um and those there
are moments right you go in these phases
where it's like uh you're just such an
[ __ ] dude
you're [ __ ] and then you're like you
know what that was a really good thing
you did and you didn't do it because the
cameras were rolling or you didn't do it
because
you wanted people to like you you did it
because you really have a heart and
there are
ups and downs of that sort of validation
and like validating yourself for certain
reasons
and um so i'm that that's all a
balancing act and that's part of the
whole therapy and all this
luck enough about me this is about you
but so you could be my therapist well
just just to add to that a little bit
and also circle back on
what i what i was going to then get into
when i was talking about
how i um kind of recognized that i was
driving so much of my work my worth from
my work another thing that i recognized
was um
dopamine and this is through
uh you know by the way this is also like
40 years of life and you know
knowing things now that i didn't know
before so i could put i cannot connect
dots that didn't make any sense
but dopamine is a really fascinating um
drug in our bodies and it's really
um a a reward
drug so uh
serotonin um is a
i mean by the way i'm not even don't
don't quote me on any of this stuff
but we're just actors talking about
things yeah you
but well serotonin uh seems to be more
of a
a love drug like kind of a more steady
feel of things are okay
right a piece or uh that kind of stuff
whereas dopamine
is the excitement dopamine is the little
shot
little and we and we and we get them
playing video games this is why people
become addicted to video games is why
people become addicted to certain drugs
that give them dopamine
um but it's also why people get addicted
to work
because every single time you achieve
a little goal you get a little shadow
dopamine
in your body it's your body you're
evolutionarily our bodies were designed
to to help us propel forward literally
you get little shots of dopamine
throughout your day when you're playing
a video game every single time you
you know you're playing a shooter game
every time you kill a guy or you
level up or you get the new gear or you
a new map opens up like
they they design apps they design games
they design them specifically for these
reasons so that you have all these
little
dopamine checkpoints like a lunch box
same thing same thing there's a little
shot of dopamine there it's a small shot
but it's dopamine go ahead
that's what i was saying you get that
little [ __ ] because you've you you've
cut you
check got that got that empire strikes
back and then it goes down
got it done yeah and it goes down and
you gotta do another one you get another
shot
right right so what i didn't realize
was i had basically stripped myself
of all of my little dopamine shots
because
i been have been grateful
uh and very blessed to have been working
as consistently as i've worked in my
career
um but that going
for the most part for the most part from
job
to job you know there are definitely
seasons of life that were drier
and it and those were also as it turns
out shocker
more depressed states uh in me um
because i didn't have enough hobbies or
other things that i was accomplishing
i was always wanting to go to work and
when i was at work
i got all the dopamine that i needed
because you
show up to work by the way getting up
this is why uh
the scientists and like there's this uh
i think there's a navy seal has this
great commencement speech and he talks
about
tucking in or making your bed in the
morning
and the reason why you make your bed in
the morning is because it's the first
shot of dopamine you get it's an
accomplishment you accomplish making
your bed
and they don't need to be big
accomplishments i do i need little
accomplishments do you do it make your
bed you make your bed
brush your teeth take the shower do
shave whatever you
all those little things you know we
don't think they are but they actually
are little teeny accomplishments wow
when it you go to work as an actor you
show up
hopefully you're on time accomplishment
you say hi
you got now you've got some community
there you're seeing your set pa or your
base camp or whatever
cool you um the director hugged you
sure when you could do it no you're now
you're rehearsing
the rehearsal process is an
accomplishment you're going through
you're figuring things out you're
figuring out where you're going to stand
and you're figuring out your
lines if you don't already know them and
you're working it out with the other
actors and the director and
all that and that's one and then your
takes and then you do it taking it's
great and then it's a dopamine
it goes on and then you go home you're
exhausted and you start the whole day
over
exactly and when you don't work you
don't have those days you don't have all
that dopamine
so what do you do well you i i think
you're doing things that are helpful in
that regard you are busying yourself
with your podcast with writing your
music but performing your music with
whatever it is your hobbies i struggle
with hobbies because i don't prioritize
them i think that in my warped thinking
for so long in my life it's like well
those are kind of a waste of time
i need to focus on the work stuff i
spend too much time screwing around and
playing video games and
doing whatever and i don't have time for
that i need to go do this stuff
so for me personally i need to invest in
me
i need to invest in me time i need like
i got a ukulele i'm learning how to play
ukulele let's write let's write a song
together let's
let's my next album let's let's do a
song why don't we do a
duet well or or i'm not kidding like i
have a duet on this album i i'm so
you're right all these hobbies like i'm
thinking the music wait a minute
i've never been more happy never been
happier never been
felt like a rush dopamine every time i
get a note back and here's the
song and we have notes and then i have
to go re-record this and even though i'm
not the you know the
i haven't been a musician in my life i
love music and i finally said
just because i'm i don't sing like adam
lambert i can [ __ ] make music
and now you can't get me away from
writing music i
love it i don't care if i become a rock
star i'm not there to be a rock star
i want to make music and hopefully
people like it and the patrons do and
and you know friends do and i love it
most importantly for the first time in
my life so maybe that is a breakthrough
inadvertently
i didn't realize that music would be
such an
important factor in my life and that is
a hobby and so maybe
you're right take the ukulele up let's
write a song
together let's go back and forth with
lyrics let's put something down and go
hey that's another
accomplishment let's just do more things
without oh
you got to also not spread yourself too
thin because you do a lot of stuff as
well
yeah and and look and everybody's got to
be able to gauge that for themselves
and you know are you overworking
yourself are you overstimulating
yourself are you not enough or you know
i that's everybody's got bandwidth i
know for
me i found myself in this pandemic
without work and not knowing how to
enjoy my own life
and i was so blessed man i was on my
ranch in texas on the river i had
family and friends that could come and
stay with me and all quarantined
together
i mean we had a beautiful situation and
yet i was still
so despondent and
one of the things that i gleaned from
that was oh because i
have put to not just to derive all of my
worth from my work
but part of the reason why i do that is
because i get my dopamine
almost exclusively from work and if i
don't have enough to do for work
and i'm telling myself well this is a
waste of time over here to go and
you know get better on my dirt bike or
mountain bike or
or get up and run every day or whatever
you know learn how to tap dance
learn a new language whatever it is
and also it's difficult when you are in
a depressive state
to believe in yourself so that makes it
harder
so before you get to that deep deep down
depressive state or even if you're in
right now recognize that you telling
yourself you can't do it is a lie
you telling yourself that you're not
worthy of doing it is a lie go and do it
fake it till you make it because you
will start giving yourself dopamine by
accomplishing
go accomplish accomplishing
almost anything we'll give you
little shots of that dopamine and that
will help pull you out of
the depression this is this is a
wonderful conversation to me this is i
you know i hope people enjoy it as much
as i do i hope everybody
listens i to me honestly back to like
it matters to me this has been dopamine
for me this has been this has been like
this is
i've learned so much and i always learn
from you
and uh i know i'm sort of the you know
the the little kid kind of just jumping
in and making a joke here and there and
i kind of like do that because sometimes
uh you know
i like to do that but sometimes it's
insecurity or it's or it's like oh my
god he's talking about exactly what i'm
getting too serious here
oh farts farts have done it again farts
have cut into the
serious talk and i'm sure people say
zach was about to say
something really important and he cut
him off with a singing the bee gees or
some [ __ ]
we're going to get into a thing called
[ __ ] talking with zach levi this is
rapid fire this isn't
this is just fast if you could do it
fast yeah this is all my patrons get to
ask these questions if you want to join
patreon patreon.com
inside of you i'll message you sophie m
what are three positive things that you
have done during lockdown
um three positive things i've done
during lockdown um
prozac
[Laughter]
um uh eating eating right
uh working out um
and meeting a lovely girl that we didn't
even get into that
we're gonna get all right all right hang
on we might get into that but we might
not i don't want to get personal i will
will you have been personal gen
d gen d gen d how has your recent social
media hiatus been
beneficial to your mental health how has
your recent
social media um tremendously
um i've
i've uh ventured back on a little bit um
but i find myself uh almost wanting to
disappear again
um it's just incredible how addictive
instagram specifically is
uh it's just the endless scroll the
endless scroll the endless scroll the
endless scroll you're just constantly i
mean
and i and i know it like you're doing it
and you know you're doing it and you
still don't stop yeah because you think
by the way this is also dopamine because
every single time you come across
one of those memes that's a golden
golden meme and you're like
i won i won i was supposed to keep
scrolling
i found the nugget and then i keep going
instead of just
ending there you go i bet i'll find
another one it's me with popcorn
it might as well be a one-armed bandit
it's me it's me with popcorn i'm like
i've had enough i'm bloated
i'm farting and i just need to stop and
i'm like no
i have half a bowl it's delicious
himalayan salt it's not the worst thing
in the world it's non-dairy butter
i'm going to finish this [ __ ] bowl
i'll even give a few more kernels to my
dogs
dopamine steph a what's something you
like to see wb
do warner brothers do that you think
would make the dceu the dc
universe better
bring back lex luthor what um
say what they did bring back lex luthor
no i know did they bring back the
alexa that's the question she asked the
oh is that what you go by now the legs
no i don't go by that some people do
screen ran to other
publications um a young gene hackman i
always refer to you as
by the way he was my favorite he was my
favorite lex luthor of all time so good
he was so good
but you don't know really that's a tough
question doesn't it uh yeah i don't know
i
you know it's
like and and this isn't just trying to
i'm not like i'm not
definitely not evading or dodging or
whatever um
or or paying lip service when i say
i'm legit just grateful that i get to
be shazam and get to be in that world
and
um as a as a comic book
fan and video game player and lover of
all
nerdy pop culture like i have all kinds
of different ideas of i think of what i
think would be fun or
cool um but
look i think that from what i've
gathered from my bosses and the
conversations that i've had i think that
that that warner brothers and dc are
making steps to do
exactly that at making it better i think
that you know there was
unfortunately just some mis steps or
misfires or
whatever uh that came in the initial
universe building that just didn't pan
out and
marvels did uh they took you know
i think feige and those guys were smart
enough to take john favreau
and robert downey jr's template uh in
the original iron man
and eventually just kind of put that
vibe
over all of their titles they realize
that that's what people
want and they were right it's it's it's
just
it's funny enough and with just enough
action and explosiveness and
death but not so much that like kids are
freaking out and parents can take their
kids to the movie
like they struck the perfect chord and
favreau and
and down he did that first and then they
used that temple and they did it
dc and zack snyder wanted to go the
other direction and be like let's
make this dark let's do it let's you
know let's do this this darker deal
and i think for batman that works i
think that
it was a difficult thing to apply to all
of the dc characters because of their
different personalities and stuff
and um uh and ultimately you know they
were trying to figure out their tone and
zach had to leave justice league and
joss came in and now there's all that
drama and all these things that people
are talking about and that was all well
before my time and
i i don't i can't weigh in on any of it
but what i can say is that
now because the universe build didn't
work i think in the way that everyone
wanted it to they have they have pivoted
and now they're allowing it to be
this um multiple ver universe
uh dc universe the the multiverse
which now which is interesting because
marvel is now kind of doing that thing
as well but it allows you to to make all
the movies you want
and they can be connected or not
connected or whatever
and i actually i think that's smarter
this this has been awesome the last
thing i want to say really quick i mean
you know is i'm really happy about the
girlfriend so why don't we see how that
goes
and in maybe five months or four months
or whatever
down the road this year you come back
and if that's still happening it
happened i wish you the best i
i you know you don't normally have
girlfriends i normally don't either it's
not because we're not
well you know uh you know we're troubled
um we're no we're i think we're innately
good people like everyone but we
we're just trying to be better and once
we like ourselves more and love
ourselves then we can love and that's
ultimately the bottom line of
of us or i can speak for myself but yeah
and i think part of that is
you know um
when you struggle loving yourself then
you really struggle allowing another
person to love you because you don't
think you're deserving of it
and you don't even know that you're
doing that but yeah you don't i don't
even know
i don't even know that that's what's
happening like you're saying
like you're not loving someone you're
like well this person's so sweet to me
and so kind to me and so
from then we get along and we don't
fight and all these things and things
and things and
why don't i love this person well maybe
because you don't love yourself
but how do you do that then is that
really the reason or is it
so it's just this battle that you have
in your head and it's just like a bunch
of lies like
you said and it's like get to the bottom
of it and
that's i think what we're doing that's
why we're here you know
amen thanks zach i uh i love you thanks
for being here again
i love you too man and i love everybody
out there listening and watching and uh
we'll see you soon you know you edit
these episodes ryan
do you i mean you have to listen you
have to really listen to them
is this something did you get something
out of this one it did what did you
notice about zach that was different
this time
zach well i haven't listened to the old
ones but um
he uh is one of them
every now and again you get you get
somebody who's just an open book and
then we'll just say
whatever is on his mind and whatever
he's going through and so he just
he let it all out he talked openly about
uh like his um
being on you know medication for
depression which he was hesitant about
and um and uh yeah so
i mean whatever you're willing to
discuss he
is open to it yeah that's true you know
i uh sometimes have guests who just
don't want to
open up as much or they have specific
things they want me to cut out or
you know there's there's reasons you
know people don't want their whole lives
out in the open and i i get the you want
to be private but
uh when those people that have a voice
that have recognition
a name celebrity status open up
they just don't realize i mean we don't
realize how much power that is
that's power that's using your celebrity
to help people
now that is beyond to me
an oscar or winning awards and all that
[ __ ] because what you're doing is you're
actually
helping people and and i think zach does
that so
and uh he deserves everything he is
getting in terms of success he's a great
guy and
um i love to see him fight in the good
fight you know i mean
um as as zach told you or zach was
talking about all the medications things
that he
things that he does things we are not
professionals
we're not licensed professionals we just
talk about our problems and
um so if you do need help you know where
to get it
uh there's better help um which can help
you
fro with online counselors there's um
and there's also emergency hotlines of
something serious and you know
uh you know if you're an emergency uh
don't listen to the podcast get going
with your stuff you know what i mean so
once again if you want to join patreon
the patreon family it's patreon.com
inside of you i write a message to you
after you join
uh also sunspin.com you can get these
our lovely cd is out they're
autographed or unsigned but there's
shirts and lunch boxes and a bunch of
stuff go to sunspin.com
sweet trucker hats look at that trucker
hat i love it i wear it all the time
and uh what else how could they
subscribe to the podcast again
uh youtube.com slash inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
inside of you pod on twitter at inside
of your podcast on instagram and
facebook yeah i'm gonna start like a
contest or something i started up for
the sun
spin like if you get 10 people to go to
the stage that haven't gone before
to see us we'll give you a zoom so
maybe there's something where um all my
listeners out there can you know they
can get
10 new listeners or something and then
they could get something some free merch
or free
something or there's got to be a way to
do that give them an incentive
if you will you know what i mean would
you guys do that
tweet me let me know if that's a good
idea
and also you could send messages which i
don't check regularly but i do check and
i look at your emails your messages and
i appreciate them the letters are so
heartfelt
uh hello inside of you
dot com hello ncidpodcast.com
that's it hello insideyoupodcast.com
um yeah sunspin.com for all the merch
and inside of your store
you can go to inside of your store
online and get all these
great shirts and uh tumblers and mugs
and
autographs there's also lex luthor
pictures and smallville lunch boxes and
[ __ ] so
there's a lot of fun stuff there and a
big shout out to all my patrons
again couldn't do it without you love
what a great community we have um
a great community we have it's it really
is uh it's it's splendid
i do these youtube lives where it's just
for patrons so it's a private link
and i just play songs and talk back and
forth with them and they're messaging me
and um
we have an occasional a big zoom for the
top tiers every couple months i'll do a
big
zoom thing um
[Music]
you know so it's it's hard too because
there's so many people leaving messages
that you can't
you can't respond to everybody you just
can't i mean i would spend every day all
day
on that and i do respond but uh
sometimes it takes me a minute and i'm
not a fast reader as my agent would tell
you
can you read the script can you just
read it and see if you like it i don't
think i'm gonna like it but
have you read it no but people just read
it read the [ __ ] script
all right let's read the patrons okay
here we go
any voice in particular to how about um
how about freddy krueger nancy
nancy d see that would take too long
though
mary yeah uh i could just read them
trisha f sarah v little lisa yukiko
jill e brian h lauren g nico p robin
asked jerry w
robert b jason w stephen j kristen k
not to be confused with kristen crook
amelia oh allison
l just j lucas m we got raj
c does amanda listen to your girlfriend
listen to the podcast ever
no he doesn't joshua d emily s cjp
samantha m jennifer n
jackie p stacy l carly h j
s jamal f janelle b carrie b tab of the
272 not to be confused with
tabitha 273 ashley ryan kimberly e
that's kimberly ewing i believe mm-hmm
uh mike e marissa
m-n ann is in nancy it's naniarello el
don supremo which is dan
jack s one of my faves ramirez
beth b santiago am sarah f chad w lee np
ray a maya p miesha
maddie s kendrick f ashley shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v
james r chris h osborne
osborne i love osborne i want to see
osborne
i don't get on zoom sorry
i'm too cool i was bjorn he's busy
launching flaming arrows at
boats we're probably way wrong it's like
i have
no time for this i'm a viking by the way
his name's probably we're probably
effing it up completely it's probably
like beijon
or abajorn and there's an o with a line
through it
amy c dave h samantha s spiderman
chase sheila g ray h alyssa c
tab of the t misha h deb a tom and
suzanne b henry s kdf liliana a
uh michelle k hi michelle marcus
he wants to marcus he wants to
hannah b michael s talia m uh
luke h john s andrew t christie s
claire m liz j laura b laurel
laura l chad b rochelle e nathan e
brandel d
taylor k neil a marion e meg k janelle p
dan and jennifer j wayne m those are
them you know i noticed a lot more names
also thank you for buying all the uh the
sunspin merch
so when rob and i were boxing them up i
see all these names we want to actually
do something with the people who bought
lunch boxes to make a video of them on
open
of them opening their video their uh
lunch boxes
and make it as creative as they can and
the most creative will get like a five
minute zoom or something with us to
as a token of our appreciation and you
gotta post on all socials
so if you get a lunch box and you get it
um
hopefully you get in time for this
contest because i think it's happening
right now but i think you'll have time
this has been a real treat thanks guys
so much we got great shows coming up
please stay tuned if you you're here for
zach levi
stay tuned for other guests i think
you're gonna learn something i learned
something every day from you from the
guest
from ryan uh from my home in the
hollywood hills rose boswell oh yeah
casa de rosenschnoz
uh i'm michael this is ryan we'll give a
little wave to the camera thank you all
for allowing
me to be inside of you today thanks much
love to you
[Music]
i i just died in your arms tonight
it must have been something you said
just died in your arms tonight